[Musik]
[Applaus]
zeit- und ortsunabhängig geld verdienen
auf meiner bisher fruchtlosen suche nach
dem leichten geld werde ich diesmal
versuchen innerhalb von einer woche
möglichst viel dame zu verdienen
online-umfragen von zu hause aus zu
beantworten ob es geht fragt ihr euch ja
das geht
dieses video wird unterstützt von huawei
ich nutze die vorzüge des online
arbeiten ist sofort komplett aus und
wird von hier draußen in der sonne
arbeiten wir fangen an mit heimarbeitern
punkt.de geld verdienen von zu hause
jetzt geld verdienen ach das ist gar
keine frage sagte selbst sondern die
bereiten nicht nur weiter auf weitere
umfrage seien hier zum beispiel meinung
studie
das ist ihr lieblings insekt was ist das
denn für eine sicherheitsfrage in europa
für schöne während vier stunden und
vielen dank für ihr interesse an unseren
umfragen wir hatten eine überwältigende
anzahl an teilnehmern und die gewünschte
teilnehmerzahl wurde reicht ja ja das
heißt ich habe ich das einfach nicht
qualifiziert für die umfrage hat weiß
ich habe fünf minuten gebraucht nur
dafür dass man die sorgen nehmen oder
deine daten die sagt aber trotzdem ein
schaum auf meinem studio hatte ich
keinen bock mehr ich probiere mal was
anderes ich hab mich jetzt bei top
online angemeldet alle daten die ich
angegeben haben sind natürlich ziemlich
falsch
und jetzt muss ich ja allerdings
übertrieben viele informationen über
mich angeben was einerseits natürlich
krasser ist anderes hat häufig dadurch
dass ich prinzipiell nur um fragen
zugelassen werde auf die ich auch passe
und da nicht immer unnötigerweise
tausend sachen eingeben
61 us-dollar ich habe jetzt alle
informationen bei talk angegeben ist hat
einfach zwei stunden mich gehört und
dann ende habe ich einfach noch
irgendwas angeklickt und jetzt bin ich
hier und ich habe nur eine umfrage zur
verfügung die 30 punkte oder umgerechnet
30 cent bringt zwölf sekunden später das
waren umfrage das ja geil
130 punkte okay das hat jetzt eigentlich
1 eur 30 da hab ich brauche allerdings
2000 punkte auf dieser seite damit ich
überhaupt etwas aussagen
das problem aber ist zurzeit sind keine
umfragen verfügbar also schaue ich mir
die rede man die nächsten anbieter an
dieser nennen sich live points und siehe
da viele umfang zur auswahl und das
beste ist wenn ich eine umfrage mache
werde ich sogar zum ersten mal richtig
vergütet hier zum beispiel umgerechnet
54 cent in zehn minuten
wir machen weiter mit meinung sword
registrieren sie sich noch heute na klar
wenn sie die teilnahmevoraussetzungen
für diesen fall erfüllen und die
fragebogen vollständig ausfüllen
erhalten sie 5 meinungs- punkte hier
gibt es also auch nur was wenn man den
bedingungen entspricht manche dienste
waren kompletter müll aber talk und vor
allem live points haben einen echt guten
eindruck gemacht mein kontostand bei
talk ist umgerechnet einen euro 30 und
bei live points 1 euro und 4 cent ich
bin gespannt welcher stundenlohn dabei
am ende herauskommt was sich am coolsten
an den umfragen finde ist dass man sie
immer und überall am handy machen kann
ihr fragt euch bestimmen was das für ein
teil ist auf dem ich die umfragen mache
ich weiß ich weiß man kann es
zusammenklappen es ist das huawei made
xs welches als ganz normal nutzbares
handy in der hosentasche verschwindet
aber mit einem knopfdruck seht selbst
sagt mirko röder smart access
zugeschickt hat knapp ich das team
völlig begeistert ständig auf und zu
versteht mich nicht falsch ich find's
cool weiterhin jetzt immer besser und
schneller werden und den jungs von
huawei ist es auch bestimmt weniger
wichtig dass ich erwähnen dass hier ein
mega grasser prozessor 8 gigabyte ram
und 500 gb speicherplatz verbaut sind
aber was ich bei handys lange zeit
vermisste hat ist innovation und das
magix es kommt einfach aus dazu kunden
die kamera oder die vier kameras sind
die besten die ich bei einem smartphone
je gesehen habe und warte keine face
kämen keine nervige nutzt ja man kann
einfach die gute hauptkamera als
facebook nutzen der riesige akku ist in
30 minuten auf 85 prozent fast voll
geladen und die hof gehring ist für
android die erste wirkliche alternative
zum google place tor und hat alle apps
grundlegend auf sicherheit und
datenschutz geprüft mehr infos findet
ihr über den link in der video
beschreibung
ich habe gerade gesehen dass beide
umfragen sei richtig viele sachen
angekommen sind und zwar bei live points
gibt es keine receiver umfragen und zwar
eine die zehn minuten dauert und mir 65
läuft bringt ich finde sie keine
nachfragen mega spannend ich kaufe mehr
lebensmittel als gewöhnlich also dass
kauf hat sich halt verändert man geht
halt nur noch einmal die woche einkaufen
und nicht jetzt eine woche vielleicht
ein bisschen mehr soziale kontakte sind
aufs kleinste reduziert beim
händewaschen beachten ich die whu
richtete und mindestens 30 sekunden
oh hat den so gut gefallen dass ich mich
gleich in vier bis sechs wochen zum
zweiten teil dieser befragung einladen
bei 575 live points sie den bereits zum
einlösen das machen wir ein blödsinn
ja ich kann mir fünf europa gut haben
jetzt holt für 600
da bräuchte ich noch 30 mehr ich könnte
jetzt auch tatsächlich schon fünf euro
amazon gutscheinen auszahlen lassen aber
ich will lieber cash also müssen wir
noch ein bisschen geduld haben bis wir
herausfinden ob ich das geld auch
wirklich überwiesen bekommen
bei talk habe ich heute leider gar keine
umfrage bekommt deswegen ist dort mein
heutiger umfrage konnte stand nach wie
vor ein euro 30 bei live points aber
immerhin schon vier euro 85 das heißt
ich habe bei lifeb uns heute drei euro
81 verdient also 2 euro 50 pro stunde
alle anderen anbieter lasse ich ab
sofort weg da ich mit ihnen keine
erfolge erzielen konnte
ok mit dieser umfrage werde ich mir
jetzt endlich meine erste auszahlungen
verdienen und zwar geht es hier
tatsächlich um influenza ich bin
gespannt auf welche dieser kanäle folgen
sie influenza sind sie jemals der
produkt empfehlung eines influences
gefolgt und haben das produkt gekauft
na klar sie sollen beurteilen ob aus
ihrer sicht die folgenden informationen
als partner in frage kommen wer jetzt
lust sich wenn ich da jemanden kennt die
kenne ich nicht kenne ich auch nicht wie
bewerten sie das image der marke und das
image der influenza in bezüglich der
folgenden kriterien zu einander und übte
studie typisch nicht komplett
komplementär des todes kilian kenne ich
auch nicht sehr willkommen denn dann
noch li na klar
die 40 live points vielen dank instagram
models auschecken und dafür geld
verdienen das ist doch schön apropos
geld verdienen wir können jetzt endlich
auszahlen lassen wenn die teilnehmer
update wird auf 624 jetzt bin ich
richtig gespannt ich bin jetzt echt mega
gespannt einlösen und jetzt hole ich mir
das cash okay die ersten fünf euro sind
ausgezahlt dauert allerdings
paar tage bis es wirklich an meinen
paypal account verschickt wurde also
werden wir doch erst später herausfinden
ob das geld auch wirklich ankommt bei
mir ich erledige alle verfügbaren
umfragen bei diesem anbieter da ich mit
den anderen bisher ja eher schlechte
erfahrungen gemacht habe beschließe ich
mich dazu noch weitere ins boot zu holen
meinungs- club hier ist die währung cash
points wir haben schon 7,6 und die sind
eins zu eins in euro umzurechnen soweit
ich das verstanden habe
das heißt wir haben hier schon 7,6 euro
aber die werden natürlich erst
ausgezahlt wenn man die vollen 25 hat
gut wenn ich der meinungsumfragen
ausführen clique komme ich einfach zu
einer seite wo ich irgendwelche cashback
prozent bekommt man halt auch keine
umfrage ausführen kann
deswegen ist der meinung ist es für mich
auch schon durchgefallen ok
entscheidungs club jetzt profil
ausfüllen guthaben bisher null euro
hätte mich auch gewundert nehmen sie
mindestens gelegentlich ein glücksspiel
teilt leute da kommt noch was auf euch
zu aber nein wie viele stunden sehen sie
im durchschnitt tv am tag gar nicht gar
nicht dann ist das profil ist
unvollständig hat auch wieder ewig
gedauert mal schauen ob sich das jetzt
lohnt umfragen in kürze hier
ich fühle mich verarscht mal schauen ob
bei tag mittlerweile was kommen gekommen
ist wir können hier eine umfrage zum
thema getränke und genuss machen für
zwei euro umgerechnet da bin ich auf
jeden fall dabei angeforderte teilnahme
zahl wurde bereits erreicht die umfrage
ist daher doch als beendet warum gehen
wir also was angetan
das ist einfach unnötig naja mal sehen
was draus wird bei talk stehe ich nach
wie vor bei 1 euro 30 main live points
konto ist mit umgerechnet zehn euro 45
immer viel versprechender und bei
entscheider club habe ich zehn sind aber
warum zahlt überhaupt jemand dafür dass
sich ein paar kästchen im internet
anklicken und was passiert mit den
persönlichen daten die ich ständig in
diese portale rheinbund einerseits
werden diese natürlich zu markt
forschungszwecken ausgewertet die
unternehmen die die umfragen in auftrag
stellen und mich indirekt für die
umfragen bezahlen wollen ja schließlich
herausfinden ob ihre kunden zb lieber
plastik oder papier verpackung hätten
aber das war noch längst nicht alles wie
die datenschutzerklärung der jeweiligen
anbieter verrät es geht sogar so weit
dass zum beispiel live points für genaue
ergebnisse nicht nur die daten verwendet
die man in den umfragen angibt sondern
sogar mit hilfe eurer emailadresse bei
allen möglichen anderen websites in
erfahrung bringt welche werbeanzeigen
ihr auf deren plattformen an
zeigt bekommt dadurch wird gemessen wie
stark ihre einstellungen welche ihr ja
in den umfragen preisgibt eventuelle
kaufentscheidungen beeinflusst so jetzt
mal eine chillige runde live points wir
haben ja mega viele sachen wieder zur
auswahl zb hier das dauert nur sieben
minuten 43 live.de geht es ihnen heute
ausgezeichnet die krise ist für
deutschland die größte herausforderung
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg das habe ich
öfter gehört aber das kann ich halt
einfach nicht bestätigen weil ich weiß
auch nicht wie das beim mauerfall war
ich weiß nicht wie man hat es für die
politik war das zu organisieren
irgendwann wird die paarung nach wie sie
ein ende haben die sind ja optimistisch
der kontostand beitrag beträgt hier
immer noch 61 bei live points
überraschende 4 10 eur 68 und bei
entscheider club immer noch 10 cent
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also ganz ehrlich ich bin echt
überrascht das ist jetzt in einer woche
30 euro dabei herumgekommen
ok klar eine woche arbeit 30 euro steht
in keinem fan ist ich weiß aber dafür
dass man gar keine voraussetzungen hat
man sich einfach mal eben anmelden kann
und dann einfach mal am abend eine
stunde lang da muss man ein bisschen rum
tippen kann und dadurch dann 30 euro in
der woche also alles andere aus live
points vernachlässige ich jetzt mal weil
nur das hat sich bei mir gelohnt und da
hab ich jetzt 10,5 stunden gearbeitet
ungefähr jeden tag anderthalb da kommen
wir auf einen stundenlohn von sage und
schreibe drei euro pro stunde ist
natürlich weit entfernt von mindestlohn
und mit euren daten wird natürlich auch
einiges getrieben wo viele von euch sich
denken ja ceni dann bin ich hier raus
also ich ein schüler war mit 16 17 der
waren 30 euro in der woche halt echt
viel geld die für irgendwelche dunklen
spieler ausgewählt können ich finde es
war ein spannendes experiment aber ich
denke meine suche nach dem gleichen geld
ist noch nicht zu ende vielleicht wisst
ihr dass das vorbei magix es mit dem
huawei mobile services anstatt der
google mobile services erhältlich ist
das umfasst auch die hauseigene app
gallery ins leben gerufen um den nutzern
unabhängig von google eine riesen
auswahl an apps zu beaten mehr infos zum
hall meetings findet ihr ein video
beschreibung ich mache jede woche einige
videos nächste woche versuche ich
innerhalb von sieben tagen den fitness
test der spezialeinheit ksk zu schaffen
wenn ihr das nicht verpassen möchte
abonniert gern diesen kanal und dann
sehen wir uns demnächst mal wieder als
gut
[Musik]